Kelly Crosby and baby Campbell from
Arizona Oh baby got front to look at
them top huh
hey guys debate club question what is
scarier ghosts or aliens gang gang buzz
buzz oh my god is that [ __ ] who's
cute man
lady is cute in the fuzz Bryan Callen
she has something on her back
it's a beautiful young man well what is
she God bro what am i scary what's
scarier ghosts or aliens ghosts or
aliens [ __ ] aliens this is an easy
one yeah pill ghost what's the worst
they can do I don't know [ __ ] with my
lights might pull my sheets back okay
cool man somebody told me once had a
dream that aliens are gonna come here
and fight black people is that crazier
what did a white person tell you that no
I don't remember who it was but I mean
otherwise there's a low key beef between
aliens and black people yeah we know
about Mexican what bro I don't think so
dude told you this no Maurice Clarett
told me the most dangerous people in
prison are Mexicans that they are the
general people yeah the moves coming
from a black guy so no somebody told me
there's beef between black people and
aliens dude I'm not a bi person I'm not
an insider-trading year I don't know so
let's go to our let's go to our ethnic
friends that are here right now are you
are you suing cats or Derick or scared
of aliens cuz they're black
I don't know if anyone's scared of them
I'm saying is there a low-key beef
between ethnicities that aren't white
I'm white I don't know we have beef
against certain things we don't we like
we have what the white people of beef
against I would say probably money taxes
water slow internet um I don't know what
chrome wire uses are no a lot of white
people like them I don't think none
otherwise don't hang out that's true me
neither
what do you think dare are you scared of
aliens I just wanna know Theo did you
get that information from the movie
independence you see Will Smith punch a
play
today Liam you're like oh there's beef
between aliens and he's kind of the
leader I remember what I was watching
but I fell asleep in out a dream that
and I and then it started to resonate
with me that there is a Loki thing going
on between black people and aliens at
and I wouldn't know about it you
wouldn't know about it you know I think
we refer to aliens you mean Mexicans I
think that's just no I'm talking about
area legally I'm talking about air
aliens are you talking about like area
50 is yeah you know what I'm saying
so Derek you ever heard of this
so-called beef I mean no Theo
okay I'm not accusing anyone black guy
though said it so that's where you get
to them you know that well I'd say this
the first time black people have a lot
of early information because first time
I learned about flat earth I was at a
pizza place a late night pizza [ __ ]
spot at a casino he told me this and two
black dudes said hey man we got to talk
to you right and I thought you know [ __ ]
was about to go down you know like they
were gonna run a train on you know oh
you thought you they're gonna beat you
up I didn't know I wasn't sure that
we're gonna do that our gamble together
talked about [ __ ] racial programs to
bloggers and hey can we talk to it oh my
god don't have me that well no dude
we'll talk about flatter well that's
what they did they standing on the beat
of a parlor and which is irony cuz
you're in a pizza parlor right and so
the PETA that whole set up and that's
the wit they said look man look at this
pizza what do you think about it saying
I was like it's there like they said is
around and I said I mean it's round but
they said but really is flat and they
these dudes explained to me Flat Earth
and I'd never heard it before and then
years later Flat Earth comes to be this
big thing you know they just you know
you know they're doing all a flat
everything for dummies but yeah I guess
it's a big thing big name for thinkers I
think but now to hear that black people
in aliens are against each other
again I I don't know if that's real
that's why I'm trying to flat earthers
I'm not hiding it from you to you is I
don't know where you got that from okay
I believe you
there might be some truth there though I
think you're I think you're looking
fused and are you hearing anything on
your front cat
aliens what about Asians in a live yeah
I know that okay
I'm glad we got that out of the way Jose
I'm yeah Wow yeah I can't stand other
agents no it's crazy though is you never
hear Asians with conspiracy 30s right
aliens they don't give a [ __ ] you have a
lot of dough really give that ghost
force to wherever the [ __ ] we're like
yes there's ghosts there
yeah well that's Logan Paul did that
yeah I know and I think he killed his
brother or there's some what happened
they stumbled up oh yeah well look man I
think you don't [ __ ] with the conspiracy
theories in like flattered [ __ ] they're
too busy make making [ __ ] what do you
mean making [ __ ] do you mean dude what
do you mean you're the one wearing all
this [ __ ] they're making I know so are
you as made in America you mean it's not
it is a little son I'm Way more scared
of aliens [ __ ] ghost what's the worst
thing that goes can do to you ghosts can
haunt you ghosts can possess your
grandmother kudos man give her some
energy goes can live at your
grandparents house forever yeah they
just hot old people I'm amazed we
haven't seen as many ghosts recently as
there were in LA there's no ghosts I
definitely see at the Comedy Store go in
the belly room turn the lights off
shit's definitely hot that's a guy
feeling on you dude is it [ __ ]
damn I thought ghosts
butters a gay ghost but yeah I'll go
aliens because they're like the bigger
ghosts they're like ghosts daddy you
know and we don't know what they're
doing they're out there they might come
by they might not but dude I'll tell you
this I'd watch a group of aliens and a
group of brothers [ __ ] throw down any
day of the week yeah you keep going back
to aliens versus black guys and I don't
mean because I heard a really fun video
game but I heard early information
aliens versus black guys the video game
yeah I play that dude good don't ah dude
that's a good game dude you hit me right
I'm one of my carpet side dude talk to
pour hey about it 51% of people said
aliens [ __ ] hey ghosts were they gonna
do
back up my broccolini get your life
together
I'm not touching